imaginem o que está do outro lado do
mundo por exemplo na austrália e vamos
esconder
chegamos a secção duas ainda encontram
18 convencional australiano jay perdida
e mobilizou hoje qo mas da espanha
os dois ao mesmo preço confesso que
fiquei bastante confusa um ato temos um
produto é utilizado de peixes 5 300
índios química mas é local
por outro temos um produto em que wesley
tem escrito sobre o lixo resultado na
minha qualidade de vida próprio jogador
mas vem do outro lado tem uma pegada
carbônica enorme conseguir a melhor
decisão aconteça eu penso e talvez até
demasiado porque acredito que todos nós
podemos mudar o mundo principalmente
decisões que tomamos queria realmente é
como conseguimos sair tanto fazer uma
pergunta
algumas perguntas quem aqui que consome
e é um consumidor que tem aqui produz
quem ela conhece quem produz os seus
movimentos e que gostaria de conhecer é
todos nós temos o direito de ver se no
dia das eleições participar
coletivamente com o nosso voto
agora infelizmente nem toda a gente de
valor essa grande vitória na história
exclusivamente poderão escolher nossos
representantes e apoiar o haiti e um
desenvolvimento pouco mas concordamos
existe outro poder que temos todos os
dias o nosso poder de decisão na maneira
como gastamos nosso dinheiro
cada vez que nós compramos um produto
nós temos apoiar uma empresa é que
continua a produzir esse produto apoiar
a marca e tem um estabelecimento que
vende
no fundo nós trabalhamos e o tempo que
nós gostamos de trabalhar é convertido
em dinheiro
isso transforma se numa ferramenta de
investimentos ea forma como nós
motorizados
estamos a construir o hoje eo amanhã
bom eu fiquei muito sempre muito além
das instituições que são tomadas
às vezes é uma decisão que é tomada num
circo momento no lugar vai ter um
impacto enorme no futuro em outros
lugares do mundo é um super poder tomar
decisões
acho que todos nós conseguimos
identificar mas foram mais pessoal com
esta questão por exemplo momento em que
seriam vamos viver e não aceitar um novo
emprego onde vamos morar só comprar uma
casa ou até aceitar um novo emprego mas
principalmente pelo grande número que
tem que se escolher o nosso curso e
nossa universidade
pra mim foi um processo longo e vai uma
grande responsabilidade que estava a
escrever a minha contribuição para a
cidade eo contributo positivo econômico
desde logo um perfil bastante claro que
a produção de alimentos é de atividade
mais importante para a cidade
o julgamento com isto descobrindo que a
agricultura é a atividade que utiliza
mais recursos mais água mais químicos
mais terra desenvolve um grande
sentimento de interesse no uso
sustentável destes jogos seria então
estudar economia ao longo dos anos e com
todos os relatórios internacionais que
temos recebidos
sabemos que a agricultura moderna
intensiva é baseada em monoculturas que
está a ter consequências desastrosas
para o planeta principalmente nível de
ilusão do solo certificação de extensão
e uma grande emissão de gases de efeito
estufa na minha vida é perceber um com
os sites que mudou para sempre a visão
que eu tenho sobre o mundo
a permacultura é para uma cultura foi
criada nos anos 70 pelos australianos
biólogo e ecólogo 1900 devido à grande
se desviar um sistema e método ficou
agricultura selvagem em que eu tentando
imitar a natureza do dia esses próprios
processo e ecossistemas naturais e
aplicadas à agricultura da permacultura
deriva da palavra permanente agricultor
que mais tarde se estendeu para cultura
permanente e é baseado em três pilares o
primeiro é cuidar da terra é ver nenhum
centavo dos recursos cuidar das pessoas
de o fornecimento de todos os recursos
que elas precisam operação insistência e
partilha justa do incidente
a permacultura é um conceito muito
extensa e muito difícil aqui em pequenos
minutos publicados
vocês podem aprender mais sobre ela num
curso 12
ia ao ler um livro enorme que 1.900
crível
no fundo é uma filosofia de vida é um
método holístico e o plano de sistemas
para humanos é o design sustentável de
de assentamentos para um monte em que
trabalha com a natureza e não encontrei
ela é que tem é um processo muito longo
de observação quando chegamos a um
treino
observando a natureza funciona os
recursos naturais que estão presente e
como podemos utilizá los da melhor forma
possível
o fim deste processo poderemos pensar e
planear ea desenhar pode resultar num
design deste estilo no fundo vamos
perceber qual é o lugar mais indicado
por essas causas onde se destacam na
paisagem onde será maxixes fazer hortas
pomares temos animais até prudente a
nossa própria energia
no fundo é na permacultura todos hoje eo
- que entrou no design tem que ter mais
do que duas funções em um ambiente
apresenta apenas porque é bonita tem uma
função foi já me sinto muito simples de
uma galinha uma galinha pode usar
alimentos podem ajudar penas por exemplo
nós eu gostava que fossem fazer um
devedor um edredom danos ainda os seus
experimentos que podem ser utilizados na
versão de hortas e jardins ó com
estradas com carbono fazer composto é
conquistar em nairobi quênia neste
próprio experimento pode resultar em
dano ou outras frases que podem por
exemplo servir para que a ser uma casa
uma estufa
o segredo é juntar o país de todos os
segmentos
desta forma vamos poder integrar os
sistemas de forma aquilo de van ao longo
do tempo funcionário e promover essas
culturas permanentes que têm queremos ao
longo do tempo virar lugares enquanto
deixava uma forma melhor do que aquela
que nós encontramos
eu fiz um curso deste mudou para sempre
a minha vida em 12 dias muito intensos
no nosso cérebro começar os políticos é
perceber como tudo está assinado e
incrível média de 15 neste planeta numa
viagem seja mesmo américa do sul depois
trabalhei seis meses de um projecto
intervir é judeu e construir casas de
materiais naturais vivem nas casas mais
bonitas que vi ano
minha vida muitos destes lugares por dia
na sua própria energia é trabalhar
muitas horas em que o mesmo metro
quadrado misturamos muitas plantas que
se autoelegeu entre ajuda esses times da
companhia por desvio de nossos próprios
cogumelos e comidas melhores refeições
que tiver alguma vez na minha vida
bom é ver uma cultura realmente fácil de
ver o mundo de outra forma e das coisas
mais importantes que fiz neste para
minha vida e para o processo e tomar uma
decisão e que eu nunca mais consegui
comprar nada só porque é bonito né faz
sentido para um enfeite
ele tem uma visão de luto em função de
si próprio produto que eu vou comprar um
porque se eu preciso para alguma coisa
mas eu compro estou a apoiar uma certa
economia e que vai ter uma consequência
ambiental que vai dar alguma forma é
favor do como eu penso e como vai a 54
empresa foi votado em portugal encontrou
na agricultura biológica é forma de
produzir alimentos que mais encontra a
via com estes com esse objetivo é
debater e biológica proíbe o uso de
pesticidas e fertilizantes chance
química e tem uma abordagem de
manutenção do solo podiam da ilusão tem
algumas técnicas de de contribuir com
uma proteção estatal para o próprio sou
envolve um grupo da minha zona
vamos ao mercado vender os produtos e eu
lhe iraí
era um ambiente incrível as pessoas
super feliz de fazer compras a conversar
entre elas é fazer trocas todos os
produtores em 3d darem-se economia eu ia
acontecer então que eu pensar como é que
isso porque o ambiente é tão bom porque
quando senti tão bem porque as pessoas
já vão respeitar sempre elas têm rodeado
de frutas e verduras frescas apanhados
no dia anterior perdidas em sistemas de
ordem cidades que a economia estava em
poder da família age pessoas estava
então de voltar a transmitir o conceito
de permacultura e observação
o bom que ele nós podemos esperar e
observar e antes de fazermos uma
compra observar nos a nós mesmos e não
cair na tentação e no impulso de comprar
algo para preencher um momento vazio e
também de observar o produto
o roto isso possível as políticas da
empresa estava então se perguntar quem é
que quem já comprou ao e passar algum
tempo percebeu que nem sequer uso o
tempo acabou por deitar fora nós pode
ter um pouco de praga trans é em ter se
todos os alimentos que são produzidos
são desperdiçados e isso traz números
que eu jamais imaginar eu recebia 40
serão 143 bilhões de euros só na europa
são desperdiçados 88 milhões de
toneladas de alimentos que foram 173 15
professor combater o desperdício
alimentar não é só competir de polícia
de produtos mas é preciso recursos de
água do solo trabalho energia é combater
o desperdício econômico ea combater um
tipo polícia ambiental os custos por
isso os alimentares contribuem 8 por
cento dos gases de efeito estufa por ano
é impossível não referir à indústria da
moda
a indústria de moda é é a segunda
investida mais poluente do mundo que de
vez em 16 ou mais produtos baratos nos
autos não sempre a acontecer pode estar
sempre a mudar isso
como é que é possível lutar contra este
consumo
queremos sempre ser bombardeadas estamos
a alimentar e cones que foram surgindo
outro lado do mundo exploram recursos
temos que fazer alguma coisa tem que ser
mais conscientes para o nosso consumo
porque o poder está nas nossas mãos é e
atividade econômica é uma resposta de
todas as nossas ações e nós temos esse
poder fazer a mudança deve começar a
mudar os nossos hábitos começar a pensar
mais no local começaram a pensar nas
pessoas que trabalham a fazer os
produtos que nós consumimos os recursos
que são utilizados e também no na
continuação desses produtos disse nós
tivemos uma visão alargada dos produtos
e todo processo deus antes de chegarem
às nossas mãos
quer de extração de materiais a
indústria o embalamento e transportes
o destino que nós damos e uso que nós
damos nossas mãos não esquecer e pensar
no que vai depois para onde os materiais
vão como elas vão ser para o sadi e o
impacto ambiental pelos bombeiros
então acho que nós podemos responder a
muitas perguntas integrados nestas três
visões a visão ambiental econômica e
social porque elas nunca estão separadas
e uma forma e nós respondemos à
sustentabilidade e de criar um futuro
melhor
entre estes trechos e porquê porque
econômica há muitas pessoas que
realmente pensam que querem comprar o
mais barato e mais rápido
todos queremos poupar para umas férias
ou para futuras compras mas a verdade é
que quando estamos a comprar vamos dar a
possibilidade de empresas desenvolverem
pode destravar e pessoas poderão
estimular a sua criatividade ser mais
autônomas e competições
estamos a produzir empoderar famílias e
ajudar as pessoas realmente estão é
fazer essa atividade econômica
como podem ver este nunca pode estar
dissociada da parte do social que quando
nós compramos um produto que estamos a
contribuir para que certas pessoas
passem certo tempo a trabalhar em certas
condições e que tenham certos celulares
portanto nós podemos ter uma visão
também mais alargado de para que
empresas afinal estou a contribuir para
pessoas que estão a pagar e casas luxo e
férias enquanto tem precisa ganhar um
salário mínimo
eu posso contribuir para empresas que
têm um cuidado em contratar as pessoas
que trabalham com elas boa parte
ambiental é que toda a gente sabe tudo o
que nós conseguimos ter um impacto não
há volta a dar
nós podemos tentar fazer esse impacto o
menor possível o mais inteligente dando
uma vida extra é todos os recursos e
produtos que utilizamos aplicando por
exemplo e com linhas circulares no dia
29 de julho depois do dia mundial da
conservação da natureza é atingimos o
dia em que os deputados
todos os recursos 5 planeta terra nos
podia dar para esse ano e grande notícia
não é que podem ver no gráfico é todos
os anos este dia e mais cedo ou seja nós
quisermos acabado de usar os recursos
que podemos conseguir um pouco de vinho
dos recursos que estão disponíveis para
o dia seguinte
nesse ritmo é isto não tem muita
consideração as futuras gerações e nós
realmente o futuro que nós queremos um
futuro para os nossos filhos para os
nossos netos e para mais pessoas podem
vir ao mundo isso o fluido de vida
maravilhosa que todos nós podemos ter
então eu não quero falar de coisas mas
eu quero falar de coisas boas e pessoal
escrito de nós temos o poder nas nossas
mãos de alimento em fazer a mudança em
pensar mais sobre o que fazemos como
faziam discursos que têm desenvolver a
economia é uma resposta às nossas ações
como as empresas e os políticos todos
nós podemos unir nos dá alguma forma em
pequena comunidade a sua família no seu
bairro na sua cidade e com o comissário
movimentos criando alguma forma soluções
uma das coisas mais importantes é apoiar
projetos que já existem momentos
iniciantes são sempre visto como um
pouco os esquisitos ao tentar um emprego
em diferentes e nem toda a gente está
aberta tenho um pouco de medo do que é
novo e diferente mas é verdade quando
este projeto consegue mostrar que são
uma solução porém se sobrados em
comunidades e então convidar vos para
integrarem conceito de permacultura
nosso poder de decisão e as futuras nas
futuras decisões que tomarem e e na
próxima vez que forem às compras que
procurem produtos locais
procure conhecer as pessoas que produzem
esses produtos que perguntem pelas suas
histórias como é que chegaram até ele
que daí é que tiveram como é que se
inspiraram e que se inspirem com elas
desde com esta frase do cenário e thomas
ancara que diz que nós devemos atribuir
nos reinventar o futuro e eu gostava de
acrescentar que nós devemos atribuir em
inventar um futuro mais competitivo
regenerativo e sustentável a brigada
[Aplausos]